okay so and
see how i i cleared i'm clearing i'm
clearing the line okay
and then uh this hand's not doing
nothing
clear the line this hand is checking
then move
this arm does not need to move
this way
moving around
this hand is the hand
that's making it go in a circle
off to the side
no more like this is too high lower than
ammo
than you have
you just want to drill it drill
it back in
even undoing it like i'm going to undo
everything on doing this is also the
skill
[Music]
okay
okay so uh you can say
[Music]
bring him in
uh
[Music]
okay
i i'm not uh
i'm not doing that things are going
around you see so
uh
so you see the same adhesion and you get
it this is the adhesion push on me push
you see we're not going anywhere i don't
need to do a pummel
like i'm wrestling i'm going around all
of this energy going around this energy
so your goal is to
not feel her
resistance
this is just a drill you see
just to drill around soft this thing's
soft
okay
try it again so you're gonna get all
this stuff to start working without you
having so much agency and moving things
okay they're already where they need to
be try it again
just sneak aside
[Music]
okay let's try it uh if you're going
with the beginner you can
just get them on your kosher
i'm gonna take my shoulder under there
oh sorry
boom right on right on top
oh
so
[Music]
there
now now you guys want the arm to go down
do you understand what i'm saying you're
always trying to get out of things so
it's it's his arm is going up maybe he's
going for his headlock you see
oh
okay you would you would feel that
energy it's going off and i take it here
right i'm not forcing the technique i'm
going with what he's giving me okay now
here
right there it is right there but
if i almost have it so for example it's
going up i'm going to be closer to it
than katakatama because his shoulder's
so high do you get it so in which case i
dropped myself
i got underneath it
now
right there if you try to bend here
he'll he can bend his elbow do you see
it like that so you have to use the
centrifugal energy to lock that in place
do you understand so you got to keep the
same circle you can't get gluttonous and
you've got you you're going to roll it
over you see but you use the center foot
feel
[Music]
here
okay